ed a tutti i ragazzi perduti questo
video sono fallite e oggi sono qui con
capito il microfono non esploso quindi
siamo a posto quindi oggi parliamo di
uno youtube a chi più di pike che cosa
questa è sbagliata la risposta io qua lo
slot e voi vi girate c'è tutto quel
bello scaffale che c'è dietro pieno di
oggetti e di sbocciati addosso quindi
sarà fantastico ragazzi ho preso due
tipi di scotch uno verde uno rosa so
perfettamente che voi mi seguite tutti i
giorni si sarebbe in grado i dettagli
non è sicuro di riuscire a chi dei suoi
amici lo butto in piscina
maronna disparità io non dico nida prima
domanda ragazzi abbiamo domanda
importante se rispondenti vaime
io non dico niente sasha ma siete capaci
ma che mi spiace così funziona la prima
è andata male che bello allora tocca a
me dai come si chiamava vincenzo vecchio
domanda stupida ed è quindi ma culo che
vj e il suo amico giorgio come si
chiamava il gameplay che hanno giocato
nella madonna che sarà qualcosa di
vecchio vado a casa da meno è lead off
la gente non sa ancora però ricordati
quello che ti sto facendo perché lo fai
anche quindi e io sono la barba e
iniziare a parlare tutta crisi consiglio
di fine estate molto calda decise di
fare un video stile spot pubblicitario
dove diceva di aver trovato una specie
di ventilatore speciale come l'ha
chiamato a fare l'allenatore a farvi
rinfrescante favi ventilatore ma ecco
magari canali vicini queste rane che
questa non prego per me giocare a calcio
fra dario e giorno fa vi già pubblicato
in cui gioca per prima volta altri dal
crac kingdoms che a questo gioco che
state parler 1243 vuoi fare i più
preparati bene a questa sfida e qua
facendo un quadro rispondere in quanto
il quale a me piace come numero
ma come come faceva per la maggiore ma
come mi passerà una bottiglia di
belvedere sa dove sia facciamo una
petizione tra l'altro non violente liti
tra l'altro non chiederei mai sono
scappati
non chiedetemi di 138 stocher o come si
chiama sua mamma beh laura
come si chiama l'avversario di vj perché
hanno cioè persone forse non sarà la
sola sola so no io c'è una bottiglia di
belvedere addosso mette vice il pesante
perché io ho fatto sto gioco un miliardo
di volte io so di cosa stiamo parlando
la passare sotto le palle ma come si
perché non hanno reso noiosamente porno
tutto ciò
lasciatemi piace tipo come la fascia del
sindaco guardate ragazze ha avuto fa vj
che secondo me una fondo mentre secondo
me uno importanti negli altri state
tutte di poter credere quanto ci sta
dice me c'è comitato è diventato rosso
salutiamo lex di pochi j ciao ragazzi
c'è tutta abbastanza per scacciare non
siete stati sinceri che pensavo avesse
risposto giugno ha risposto uno perché
pensavo solo una seria vagliamo di
robben fronte robben orobator on the run
ora un po male all'inizio però è normale
quanto dovrò la sua serie super che ogni
che avete visto conta 5 abitati io so
tutto persone a sera
pensavo ma non a me vado io a casa ma
questa è la sua i ragni a quale gli
stupri italiana assomigli kg ai
risultati della terapia
greta greta c'è in culo della mamma
ma quanti che diva migliaia fatto il
gioco mai la cercando tempo è sbagliato
ma va bene vieni pieni che cos'è sta
roba tavola ouija a porre la mano ma
trattamento divise ragazzi a dopo la
facciamo ti stende sul tavolo così
inizia quando e san lorenzo allora
signore signore adesso parla di roma
qualche alcuno di moderna che ora io
chiamo molto lorenzo
matteo non è quindi so che il 10 agosto
signore si è notato questo nome per
avere più iscritti ma allora che
facciamo loro ep se l'oro e pisa nel
video sono fidanzato come soprannominata
la prima ragazza di parla con me solo
allora potremo allora io lo so allora
filippina no dai
gerrard a gertrude ambra è vero vedi che
lo statuto lario l'avviso dai por creo
ambrogio gertrude ambrogio gertrude una
di queste due vero da e datemi una mano
è già padre file di qua
raga mi spiace io questa roba qua l'ho
presa per questo motivo e dagli da una
vita
come ti siedi la domanda non rischiasse
di prova ok presenti adesso mi parve
aiuto le prossime due le fate insieme e
vi scoccia insieme poi abbiamo finito
chi ha portato parigi su minecraft per
chi non penso proprio di non credere l
opera che giocano casillas tecniche sul
ring in tavola male però puoi fare così
no l'ho fatta giusto era me l'ha fatta
breve discorso tutta la famiglia aspetta
quando stoppa fa vigerà esiste poi
pensate ma vj questo trauma pd mette
bizet insieme non è capito maniaco porco
la guardo figlio paolo bottero ce l'hai
a quattordio ma starà che l'ultima
abbiamo finito ci siete con le nocciole
resistette raga screen a [ __ ] fare
idee e ciò il naso rai ma io c'è una
barba una cartucciera il naso ma vigile
di dai video call o la madre movie maker
remake nessuna di queste non credo che
lo fai con me
e uno che non lo sgoverno permette di
cercare le domande difficili pure abbia
matteo ahi ahi ahi a ma tu sei tiri di
là mi tiri di quattro semi stai
scocciato le gambe ma che cos'è questo
prodotto resistere cos'è un kit con
utili per ok ma vediamole già peggio
cioè la tuba che non ce la facciamo
allora fa vj affatto video su neighbor
serio le borse ma dove aspetta dai se
non era affatto solo la prima devono da
sempre capace di questo di castrette
grande capo semplice direzione basta
la donna concludiamo al video o mi stai
mister affidando o no davvero così mi
impicco ferla ragazzi io ringrazio mette
il viso per aver partecipato a questo
video molto bello al fratello qualcosa
sia d'oro ciao raga duster ragazzo non
era grave
no non tirare io non so quando la guarda
sono immobile lo vedi che non tirando
verso cosa sia accesa non sono una che
si potesse accende
[Musica]